Caption: welcome back if you could grab your
Caption: seats we've got some lightning talks
Caption: Lightning Fast lightning talks and I
Caption: didn't get a biography so I've just made
Caption: this up after a very brief chat I
Caption: actually know Brendan so I have a
Caption: Fighting Chance Brendan's coming to talk
Caption: to us first for 10 minutes followed by
Caption: Dan who's over here Don
Caption: auto correct
Caption: um
Caption: Brendan is in my words not his but
Caption: possibly his too who knows a kick-ass
Caption: consultant and a data magician
Caption: some certainly what he was doing when we
Caption: worked together and then Don not Dan
Caption: um is a multiple hat wearer working in a
Caption: homegrown Aussie quality consultancy and
Caption: by all accounts doing an awful lot of
Caption: stuff so he might be a bit tired lots of
Caption: energy for Don take it away Brendan very
Caption: much
Caption: um
Caption: data magician in the sense that I make
Caption: my data magically appear and disappear
Caption: um so I'm going to be talking today
Caption: about best practice and why we should
Caption: ban it from our vocabulary
Caption: forever no excuses
Caption: so first of all what is best practice
Caption: best practice is
Caption: defined in a couple of ways so the
Caption: definite dictionary definition
Caption: is really around
Caption: research and replicable
Caption: um replication of it basically
Caption: um a second definition I found was
Caption: essentially following the same the same
Caption: theme around replication uh research and
Caption: really just really going through the
Caption: different options and finding out what
Caption: is best
Caption: however
Caption: that is often not what people mean when
Caption: they talk about best practice
Caption: uh so first of all I'm going to say that
Caption: again I am a consultant I work across a
Caption: range of different Industries different
Caption: clients different teams and across the
Caption: board everyone's doing things
Caption: differently everyone thinks they're
Caption: doing best practice
Caption: everyone's doing it differently so that
Caption: should say one thing in and of itself
Caption: that everyone thinks best practice or
Caption: what's best practice to their problem
Caption: is different
Caption: so what do people really mean when they
Caption: say best practice and I'm sure some
Caption: people will recognize what they really
Caption: mean in a few of their conversations but
Caption: a lot of the time people are saying in
Caption: conversations when they're deciding what
Caption: uh what solutions to go for they're
Caption: really just saying well this is what I
Caption: know so therefore this is what we should
Caption: do
Caption: or or somebody else did it this way
Caption: therefore we should do it this way
Caption: but it doesn't really capture a lot of
Caption: intricacies that we face when we deal
Caption: within deal with the project within a
Caption: company so what organization a did isn't
Caption: necessarily what organization B should
Caption: do
Caption: so when we talk about best practice it
Caption: doesn't actually give any real
Caption: information we're not saying that this
Caption: option is better because of X Y and Z
Caption: we're simply saying it's better because
Caption: it's best practice and you can't really
Caption: argue with that
Caption: so
Caption: to elaborate on that a little bit
Caption: when people talk about best practice
Caption: they really are using it often as a
Caption: shield in these in these conversations
Caption: so kind of going well this is what I
Caption: know therefore I'll say it's best
Caption: practice and then they can't really
Caption: argue with me because how can you argue
Caption: against best practice it's best practice
Caption: it's why it's called best practice and
Caption: that is a genuine conversation I've had
Caption: so
Caption: people will also use this as
Caption: a way to
Caption: um
Caption: also is a bit of a shield when they
Caption: don't really understand what it is that
Caption: they're trying to do as well so people
Caption: who for example trying to set up a data
Caption: warehouse they know they want a data
Caption: warehouse they don't really know
Caption: what it needs to do and who it needs to
Caption: be used for so they start throwing
Caption: around things like best practice and
Caption: they'll go well we need a Kimble star
Caption: schema because it's best practice and
Caption: it's like is that really going to meet
Caption: our requirements is that really going to
Caption: be useful for the end users like what
Caption: are we actually trying to do
Caption: second of all it gets often used to
Caption: promote things people
Caption: teams organizations they often want to
Caption: say yeah I'm doing best practice as
Caption: almost a badge of honor
Caption: to kind of say well we're doing better
Caption: than you but as I mentioned at the start
Caption: different organizations have different
Caption: problems different solutions everyone's
Caption: doing things differently
Caption: you know none they're not not
Caption: necessarily saying someone doing it good
Caption: some are doing it bad it's different
Caption: because the environment is different the
Caption: people are different the organization's
Caption: different the problems are different the
Caption: it infrastructure is different
Caption: and finally
Caption: some people especially in the leadership
Caption: role will often use the term best
Caption: practice
Caption: to kind of Escape some of the
Caption: responsibility
Caption: so they'll go oh we need a data
Caption: warehouse
Caption: they don't want to make decisions around
Caption: well what are we going to implement what
Caption: infrastructure are we going to use
Caption: they're going to say well we're going to
Caption: implement best practice
Caption: and
Caption: that really just erodes some of this
Caption: that the team sort of make up you're not
Caption: listening to different ideas and it's
Caption: really taking away their responsibility
Caption: for the decision
Caption: you know if something goes wrong they go
Caption: well it was best practice you know it's
Caption: not my problem it's best practice
Caption: so
Caption: what are these problems really what is
Caption: this actually causing problems with our
Caption: projects first and foremost
Caption: it's really ignoring different ideas
Caption: that are being put forward if you put
Caption: forward something a different idea
Caption: people are often shooting it down
Caption: because it's not best practice or they
Caption: don't deem it to be best practice again
Caption: I'm hoping the theme Here is that
Caption: there's no such thing as best practice
Caption: but a lot of people will discount things
Caption: simply because they don't know it
Caption: therefore it's not best practice
Caption: therefore we shouldn't do it
Caption: with promoting it often breeds a very
Caption: toxic work culture where people's ideas
Caption: are not shared and valued it's very much
Caption: about promoting well we're doing best
Caption: practice therefore we're better
Caption: therefore you should listen to us and
Caption: I've worked across many teams where this
Caption: has actually occurred
Caption: and finally
Caption: avoiding this responsibility really does
Caption: create a lack of leadership within the
Caption: the the project team and even within the
Caption: wider team of stakeholders
Caption: so
Caption: overall trying to take the concept of
Caption: best practice is really removing that
Caption: visibility and understanding of on the
Caption: ability to be able to articulate some of
Caption: these these Concepts and the reasons why
Caption: we should be doing something you know we
Caption: shouldn't be doing something because
Caption: it's best practice we should be doing
Caption: something because it solves a to
Caption: constraints B
Caption: for user C
Caption: so
Caption: the ability to articulate Solutions
Caption: does create a few bit extra benefits
Caption: that
Caption: you can't really get when you start
Caption: talking about best practice first one is
Caption: building trust you start building trust
Caption: with people when
Caption: so I take for example if you start
Caption: talking about best practice
Caption: um you're not really creating a a sense
Caption: of trust with your users you're saying
Caption: trust me I know what I'm talking about
Caption: whereas if you explain the reasons why
Caption: and you start engaging with clients and
Caption: users it starts to build some of this
Caption: ability to generate the the trust that
Caption: they go okay this person does understand
Caption: our problems this person does kind of
Caption: understand our Solutions maybe I should
Caption: listen to him
Caption: secondly it generates buy-in so
Caption: going that extra step further than
Caption: explaining why we're doing something
Caption: rather than just using the term best
Caption: practice we start generating buy-in from
Caption: different stakeholders
Caption: different users people within the
Caption: project group because they understand
Caption: why
Caption: especially from a junior perspective
Caption: with Junior people coming in if we say
Caption: you're doing that simply because it's
Caption: best practice they're not learning
Caption: they're not understanding why they're
Caption: not going that one step further to say
Caption: well what is it that we're you know
Caption: trying to achieve and what are our
Caption: constraints what are what are some of
Caption: these these issues that we need to work
Caption: through
Caption: and finally we create a shared Vision so
Caption: when people if we do come across a
Caption: problem people can go look I know what
Caption: we're trying to do let me find a
Caption: solution to that and so they've got a
Caption: better understanding as to what
Caption: they're looking for they can go that one
Caption: step further they can use their
Caption: initiative because they're bought on
Caption: board as to the reasons why
Caption: so how do we achieve this
Caption: firstly we understand the problem and I
Caption: know this is going to stand very very
Caption: basic for a lot of you but we understand
Caption: the problem so starting from that
Caption: problem first
Caption: we then start to organize some of these
Caption: organizational priorities so
Caption: understanding not only what the problem
Caption: is but why it's a problem and what
Caption: they're trying to achieve from it
Caption: understanding constraints so these can
Caption: be anything from cost to to the politics
Caption: again
Caption: going into an organization as a
Caption: consultant a lot of the times we
Caption: we have to navigate things like politics
Caption: we have to navigate their environments
Caption: we need to navigate various different
Caption: things like even the people some people
Caption: you know all those those personalities
Caption: that you need to navigate and when we
Caption: start throwing in best practice you're
Caption: basically just creating a Barren going
Caption: trust me I know what I'm talking about
Caption: um then exploring the options so once
Caption: you understand what it is we're trying
Caption: to achieve and putting that towards then
Caption: coming up with the different options now
Caption: these you could go through and say best
Caption: practice
Caption: Etc but not using the term best practice
Caption: going cool we can solve this and this is
Caption: a good option to go for because it meets
Caption: our constraints it meets our problem it
Caption: meets our goals and suddenly that's a
Caption: much more powerful story
Caption: um and then as a team deciding what
Caption: solution to go for
Caption: um and so this is then taking it from a
Caption: solution-driven approach where we're
Caption: going all right let's find best practice
Caption: and Implement that to okay what are we
Caption: trying to solve cool we're going to
Caption: implement something that's solving that
Caption: problem
Caption: so to kind of quickly sum up because
Caption: I've been given the one minute warning
Caption: um
Caption: it's not about changing an entire way of
Caption: working but just changing our mindsets
Caption: to ban the term and I ban the term best
Caption: practice from all of my teams if my
Caption: teams are coming up to me talking about
Caption: problems and they use the term best
Caption: practice I tell them to go away and come
Caption: back to me when they've actually
Caption: done that research and gone come back
Caption: with an actual plan
Caption: um and so it just start with just
Caption: Banning those two terms best practice
Caption: thank you very much there's my
Caption: references and thanks to the sponsors
Caption: [Applause]